thanks for joining us America Candace is
with us in New York hi Candace how are
you hi baby how are you thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up um so I just want to know
if you have any tips on saving a house
cash because my husband and I were
really hesitant on the idea of getting a
mortgage and you also want to know if
we're saving cash should we still
contribute to retirement while doing
that because we don't want to fall
behind on retirement yeah how old are
you I'm 26 my husband's 25 okay good
okay
and you're debt-free already and have
your emergency fund yeah we became that
free last month and we'll be done with
our emergency fund by the end of this
month very good good for you well done
well done and so how much can you save a
year if you don't do retirement and it
looks like we can save um if we're
really really strict on ourselves it
looks like we can say probably about
36,000 a year without retirement okay
and how much are you wanting to save
total I'm well we were thinking of just
starting with a really small house on in
our area maybe buying like a co-op which
is pretty popular over here or a condo
first around like 200,000 and then just
keep saving and move up in house from
there
right okay so if you came you know you'd
be at about a five-year plan if you're a
little under 200,000 right 36 thousand
divided into two hundred thousand right
well it would be six years roughly if
you do the full 200 a little over two
hundred but somewhere between 150 and
200 you could do it in about five years
not counting getting raises and not
counting saving even more that's the
most I would want to go I don't want to
wait much more than five years to buy
and I don't want to wait much more than
five years
out of your retirement system so yeah I
mean whatever you're going to do I would
try to do it in under that but then so
the point is you're sitting with a paid
for property no payment in the world at
that point right and you're making
really good money and you're 37 31 32
years old right and so can you be can
you become a multi-millionaire doing
that absolutely you can okay now you
just pay yourself a house payment from
age 30 to age 60 you'd be a
multimillionaire
right okay okay great so we'll we'll go
ahead and would you recommend maybe if
we did would you think it'd be might be
a good idea to do maybe like 10 to
retirement and say maybe a little bit
less it's up to you if you're gonna go
longer than five years I'm starting to
get pretty nervous about it okay okay if
you're gonna be under five years and you
want to do zero in your case you're
still going to be very young and without
a house payment when you pay cash for
this house okay 31 years old is very
young with zero house payment you've got
the income for the rest of your life to
build wealth with I mean if you'll just
keep paying attention again pay yourself
a house payment plus or minus a little
you can be a multi-millionaire okay
great thank you so much David I
appreciate your advice very well done
good job you're thinking hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]